Okay.
I really see twitter and facebook to a
slightly lesser extent,
but really twitter as,
um,
routing devices for human attention.
Um,
they're very good at that.
They're effectively providing our
species with a common nervous system,
which we can use to transmit signals to
each other.
And so when there's something that,
uh,
is a very provocative or disturbing
signal or a beautiful signal,
it's,
it's a great system to get a lot of
humans attention directed at that thing
very,
very quickly.
And that can actually happen in a matter
of moments.
Now our minutes.
So as routing devices,
twitter and facebook are,
are incredibly effective.
And I think they do that very elegantly.
I think it's self expressive mediums.
They're less elegant and I actually
don't think they're designed to be self
expressive mediums in the same way that
a blank piece of paper and a pen is
designed to be a self expressive medium.
And so when I think about,
uh,
like cowbird and how it relates to
services like twitter and facebook,
I really see twitter and facebook is
routing devices that can route attention
to experiences and cowbird stories more
as the experiences themselves.
I had noticed a few trends happening in
online culture in general but also just
in culture more generally over the last
few years.
And um,
there were really four that sort of
struck me that as things that I wanted
to,
to transform it to reverse a little bit.
Um,
the first one is compression.
one thing we've seen actually predating
the web but accentuated with the web is
the compressing and shortening and
speeding up of communication.
So you can go back to like letter
writing,
which gave way to a eventually telephone
calls,
which then gateway to faxes,
which then gave way to emails,
which then gave way to,
uh,
text messages and chats and tweets.
And each successive level gets like more
and more compressed and shorter and
faster.
And we're sort of like hovering at the
tweet right now.
And it was unclear to me that there's
another level of compression after that.
There may be as one more like maybe we
start grunting at each other or
something,
but,
uh,
we've pretty much hit a kind of terminal
velocity,
I think,
uh,
in terms of how fast communication can
go.
So then you ask the question like,
what happens after that?
And,
uh,
do we continue to do that mode or do we
hit some kind of wall and bounce back in
the other direction?
I'm craving a little more depth and
substance again.
And so I was betting on that happening
and wanting to help that happen.
So,
um,
so this first trend of compression,
I was,
uh,
I was interested in transforming into a
kind of deepening a,
not necessarily a lengthening,
because I think that our brain chemistry
is actually different now.
And you cannot expect a large portion of
the planet to sit down and read a 500
page novel anymore or even go to watch
an opera for three hours anymore.
Some people will do that,
but those are not the mediums that are
going to resonate most broadly with,
uh,
the human species right now.
And I think you have to understand the
time you're living in and what are the
most resonant mediums of that time.
And then designed to those.
Related to that was the second trend had
noticed,
which was a kind of a disposability like
a lot of the stuff that we put out there
into the world as individuals,
we have this sort of complicit
understanding that it's going to be
swollen up and replaced moments after we
publish it by the torrent of new stuff
that comes after it.
There's this sense of just,
uh,
expressing yourself in a kind of
disposable way that,
um,
won't have any sort of lasting impact.
This was very different from something I
had experienced when I was younger,
when I was a lot younger.
And when I was working more with
physical art,
I used to keep these incredibly
meticulous sketchbooks filled with
plants and ticket stubs and um,
dead insects and watercolor paintings
and writings and all of this stuff.
They were like this sort of living
testimony of my life every day.
And they were incredibly time consuming
to make,
but each time you added a page,
it got more and more beautiful.
The overall thing got more and more
beautiful.
And over the course of years you just
have these incredibly meaningful objects
that are kind of a mirror of your,
of your lived experience.
And so that kind of timelessness,
um,
that slowly building something over
time,
which becomes more and more beautiful
over time.
I had never had that feeling on the
Internet,
like everything on the Internet was
always about the moment,
but not even in the kind of like new
agey Buddhist sense of being very
present,
but just more in terms of novelty,
like what's new,
what's the latest,
what's the latest?
And um,
and so I was interested in taking that,
uh,
that sort of disposability and trying to
transform it and do a and do a
timelessness.
The third major trend I noticed was a
curation.
So people were increasingly expressing
themselves through the stuff that they
thought was cool.
Um,
so there are web services like pinterest
and Tumblr.
And twitter and facebook,
which have,
um,
really encouraged this type of self
expression in our culture.
It's a lot easier than creating things
directly to assemble lists is easier
than to come up with original stuff.
And so I noticed that a lot of,
um,
self expression online was taking the
form of curation.
It's kind of like walking into someone's
apartment and like judging them by what
they have hanging on their walls,
uh,
and sort of talking to them.
So I was interested in taking this
curation and turning it into like a
create just creation again.
Um,
and then the fourth trend I noticed was,
uh,
this kind of self promotion.
It's like life as an advertisement.
This is something I think we all feel to
different degrees when we fill out our
facebook profiles and when we develop
these online personas for ourselves,
there's this way that we try to
advertise ourselves and look as awesome
as we possibly can.
Like,
look how hot my girlfriend is,
look how wild my party was,
look how fun my vacation was,
all of these things.
But I think that creates a lot of
unhealthy tendencies in people because
you start comparing yourselves to
others.
Uh,
you're always looking for ways to look
cooler than you are leads to insecurity
and anxiety.
So I was interested in taking that self
promotion and turning it into more of a
contemplative self reflection.
Okay.